maría clara definitivamente el llamado a
unas elecciones donde se participe de
forma masiva se ha cumplido en este
momento me encuentro en la universidad
nacional autonoma de tegus de honduras
aquí en tegucigalpa en donde se
registran grandes concentraciones de
hondureños ejerciendo su derecho al voto
y el llamado para que éste sea una
fiesta electoral en paz una fiesta
cívica en paz las los diferentes centros
de votación abrieron a las 7 de la
mañana --hora local-- sin embargo se
registraron denuncias de aperturas
tardías sobre todo por un problema
tecnológico y es que recordemos que en
este en estas elecciones honduras
invirtió el mayor presupuesto de su
historia para unos comicios hablamos de
1800 millones de lempiras el equivalente
a 75 millones de dólares en la compra de
escáneres biométricos en la compra de
lectores de huellas para evitar un
fraude por último los órganos
electorales han hecho un llamado a los
candidatos favoritos para la presidencia
a que no se declaren ganados antes de
tiempo porque aquello podría exacerbar
los ánimos de los diferentes partidarios
y provocar manifestaciones que deriven
en enfrentamientos entre manifestantes y
la fuerza pública entonces que esperen
hasta que sea el propio consejo
electoral quien dictamine quién será el
nuevo presidente de los hondureños si
andrés y usted habla a propósito de los
aspirantes favoritos y al respecto hay
dos candidatos que puntean en las
presidenciales y por primera vez hay una
mujer con bastantes opciones de ser la
presidenta cuéntanos un poco más de
quiénes son estas personas y que
representan
bueno los dos candidatos favoritos
representan la izquierda y la derecha
respectivamente hablo de xiomara castró
ella es la líder por el partido libertad
y refundación libre y nasry asfura él
representa al partido nacional que es el
partido del oficialismo el partido del
actual presidente juan orlando hernández
en cuanto a xiomara castró ella es la
esposa de manuel zelaya recordemos el
presidente depuesto en el año 2009 por
un golpe de estado y desde entonces ha
sido xiomara castro quien ha liderado
movimientos de izquierda y ha salido a
las calles a protestar primero por la el
golpe de estado en contra de su esposo
pero también por los actos de corrupción
denunciados en contra de los mandatarios
de los mandatarios del partido nacional
de la administración de juan orlando
hernández y ha dicho que de llegar a la
presidencia ella desarticular ahí abro
comillas las estructuras criminales del
partido nacional justamente del partido
nacional es el candidato oficialista
nasry asfura él funge actualmente como
el alcalde de tegucigalpa se le celebra
revestimiento infraestructura a la
ciudad pero también se le critica un mal
manejo de fondos el sería la
continuación del actual presidente juan
orlando hernández acusado de vínculos
con narcotráfico señalado por actos de
corrupción y también por la represión
civil